at year one when you start dating a  check as soon as a chick's like hey Rich  I dig your Vibe Where Do We Stand we've  been seeing each other for a while I  want to claim you I don't want anybody  else to have you can we be exclusive  blah blah as soon as you get to that  point that's when you start looking at  her going okay  she doesn't have any of my red flags  daddy issue she's not a feminist she's  not unhappy or unlucky she doesn't try  to compete with me she doesn't keep men  around from her past she's not poor with  money she's not violent she doesn't have  extreme jealousy she's not a party girl  she doesn't have tattoos or piercings  she doesn't have a big Notch count not a  single mom she doesn't seek validation  online she's not a sugar baby she's not  a pathological liar doesn't have baby  rabies doesn't throw Hissy Fits I'm in  full control of the birth birth control  she's not a drama queen and she doesn't  have an addictive personality